[Music]
hello everyone I am in the best possible
position standing between you and lunch
so thank you all so much for coming
today I want to talk to you about the
various ways in which we've invested in
running hashtag or vault on GCP over the
past year and a half to two years this
is a kind of high-level introductory
talk I will be doing some live demos but
we're not going to really be getting
deep on any one topic so this is more of
an overview of some of the ways that
we've made investments in the past year
and a half to two years Lake mano said
my name is Seth I work on the developer
relations team here at Google my twitter
handle is south fargo if you have
questions comments complains or concerns
you can tweet at me please don't
complain but otherwise fine if you have
questions you don't feel comfortable
asking publicly my direct messages are
also open so you can feel free to send
me a direct message cool so with that
let's go ahead and get started I want to
provide a quick overview of what is
vault for those of you they might not be
aware and then we'll jump into some of
the GCP specific things that we've been
working on so in order to talk about
vault it's important to talk about what
is a secret when we talk about a secret
we're specifically talking about
anything that can be used to authorize
or authenticate so that might be a
username and password an API token a TLS
certificate but it also might be
something that's personally identifiable
or business intelligence data like a
social security number or credit card a
passport number the API key to access
your internal analytics dashboards that
give you a competitive advantage in your
market and given this problem and given
that secrets are a common attack vector
because they often have overly broad
access or they access critical systems
data we often ask questions like how do
our applications get secrets how do
humans get secrets how are secrets
updated how are they revoked who is
using this secret right now why are they
using it when are they
with it and what do we do in a
compromise because as much as we would
like to protect our secrets and make
sure that no one ever has access to them
at some point we have to accept the
reality that an attacker is going to
exploit a vulnerability in our software
or in our humans and they're going to
get access to our secrets so we need a
plan for rotation and we need a plan for
revocation what is the worst-case
scenario how quickly can we recover so
what is our mean time to patch a CVE
what is our mean time to recovery in
case of a leak so vault is an open
source tool it's written in go so it's
free and open source that is designed to
answer these questions and many more it
tries to be a single source of secrets
for your organization it provides
programmatic access so that machines and
humans can access the API but it also
has a CLI and a UI for human access so
humans can interact with the API or the
UI and then machines or other
applications and services can interact
with the API directly and it's important
that to note that it's cloud friendly so
volt doesn't require that you have some
special hardware or some special
hardware device attached to a physical
machine this runs on you know native VMS
and any cloud provider including GCP so
it's very cloud friendly works very well
in the cloud ecosystem you can even run
it in a container vault stores all of
its volt encrypts all of its data in
transit using TLS 1.2 or most recently
1.3 for client authentication the data
is encrypted at rest with 256 bit AES
GCM encryption and it offers a
hierarchical key value store for storing
data so it's a path based approach to
storing data and the data inside a
secret is a key value pair one of the
things that's really interesting about
vault is that it offers dynamic secrets
so in a traditional world let's say I
need a database username and password to
connect to my my sequel instance well an
operator has to provision that
credential by running you know create
user in the sequel command and then they
take that username and password and they
put it in a text file to give it to the
application with vault vault can
actually run
sequel for you and provision that user
automatically so a human never sees the
credential only the end application sees
the credential and this helps you
maintain provenance a one-to-one mapping
between a credential and the application
or service that's consuming it this
gives us a really tight audit trail and
it allows us to time-bound our
credentials so instead of having a human
creative credential that lives forever
we can have a machine create a
credential that's valid for 24 hours or
a week or a month and by Auto expiring
these credentials we reduce our surface
area for an attack we reduce the number
of credentials and we reduce secret
sprawl and more importantly we can
revoke any of those credentials at any
time in the event of a data breach
humans or machines authenticate to vault
by providing some type of credential
vault then goes to these third-party
databases things like Redis my sequel
Postgres or as we'll see in a bit Google
Cloud and dynamically generate
credentials on the fly and return them
to the requester each time someone
requests a credential they get a brand
new unique credential and Voltas
pluggable so I already mentioned like
post Grass Mike my sequel post grass etc
basically any sequel database including
Oracle and MongoDB and sequel server are
supported for the database side of
things there's also cloud provider
supporters so at Google we have
full-time engineers who are contributing
support to vault
there's also plug-ins for other clouds
for your multi cloud strategy like AWS
or assurer or Oracle or VMware but then
there are other systems that we jet that
we don't think of when we talk about
secrets but things like rabbitmq how do
you get that API key out there
things like SSH access how do you
maintain the ability for people to SSH
into systems things like managing TLS
certificates running your own PKI
infrastructure vault can actually act as
a certificate authority or an
intermediate Civic certificate authority
providing TLS or mutual TLS
authentications between your micro
services it obviously integrates really
well with other tools in the hash Corp
ecosystem and most recently you can also
use it to provision active
three users as well as open I deeper
connect providers so what are some ways
that you can use vault with GCP so we've
made a few key investments and a few
areas that allow you as Google Cloud
customers into Google cloud consumers to
gain the benefits of running vault as an
open source product on GCP while
leveraging other GCB tools and
technologies and the first one I want to
talk about is storage backends so vault
itself is actually a stateless service
it instead has pluggable storage
backends storage back-end is just where
vault puts its data the easiest one to
think about is the filesystem vault is
just going to write its data to the
filesystem
it also has an in-memory implementation
where it will store all of its data in
memory and when you stop the process all
of that data is lost it's great for
local development but in production how
could you run vault against a storage
back-end that's highly available
provides high availability high
durability but also is low maintenance
right ideally you don't want to carry a
pager just for your storage back-end so
we've made some key investments on GCP
the first storage back-end which is
probably the most common among our
customers is the Google Cloud storage or
the GCS storage back-end this is a GCP
native storage back-end you create a
Google Cloud Storage bucket you grant
vault or a service account running vault
permission to read and write data from
that storage bucket that'll give you
three and a half nines of availability
you don't have to carry the pager we
carry that pager for you and it allows
you to run vault in high availability
mode so this allows you to run multiple
vault instances in high availability
mode for you another storage back-end we
offer for our enterprise customers or
for customers need a little bit more
availability as our Google Cloud spanner
storage back-end Google Cloud spinner is
GCP native it gives you five nines over
the availability and the highest
configuration also supports vaults high
availability mode it also supports vault
enterprise if you're running hash Corpse
proprietary Enterprise offering it's
supported on spanner but not GCS because
of the way that vault Enterprise
requires a transactional interface
again both of these storage back-end
support high availability both of these
storage backends are available with zero
maintenance to you Google carries the
pager and the slides that I'm showing
you here are exactly how easy it is to
add this configuration to your vault
server config it's just three or four
lines of configuration and the iam
authentication and now you're using a
Google cloud supported storage back-end
both of these storage backends were
contributed by Google engineers to vault
core they're available in the vault open
source distribution you don't need to
install a plug-in or run any sidecar
applications you can download vault
today or really any of the recent
versions of vault these configuration
stands ups will work out of the box they
also support GCP native default
application credentials that means if
you're running vault on a Google compute
engine instance a Google container
engine instance or Google kubernetes
engine instance cloud run cloud
functions anything that supports
instance metadata you can attach a
service account to that VM or that
underlying runtime and it will
automatically authenticate so you don't
have to worry about passing around a
service account so those are the storage
backends now let's talk about secrets
engines so in vault secrets engines our
pluggable systems that allow us to
extend vaults functionality and there
are two secrets engines that I want to
talk to you about today that can really
help accelerate the way that you do
security with DCP the first is our iam
secrets engine so this is our Google
Cloud Identity and Access Management
vault secrets engine plug-in it's a
mouthful what this allows us to do is to
configure vault to generate ooofff to
access tokens for provisioning access to
Google Cloud so what I do is I configure
vault with a service account and some
permissions and then I say hey vault I
would like you to generate service
accounts or oauth2 tokens for me
whenever someone interacts with this
path what vault is going to do is it's
then gonna make the various API calls to
Google Cloud and it will generate an
OAuth 2 access token which expires in a
certain amount of
in this example 60 minutes so this is an
OAuth 2 access token that you can use to
sign and authenticate requests to Google
cloud and they're automatically cleaned
up after that 60 minutes expires unless
you write this yourself vault is
actually the only way today to have time
based G cpi-m credentials that
automatically expire this allows you to
provide automated short-term access to
your various Google resources with very
little overhead so you imagine you have
some batch process that needs to get
some information from a cloud storage
bucket decrypt it with Cod KMS run some
data and store the results somewhere you
can leverage a storage back-end like our
secrets engine like this to generate
those credentials for you that
automatically expire whenever the job
expires so you don't have to worry about
leaking those credentials or having a
long-running service account with
permissions the next secret engine which
is one of our newest secret engine is
the google cloud KMS secrets engine this
secrets engine is an abstraction on top
of google cloud KMS our key management
service the google cloud KMS secrets
engine allows you to create manage
delete update encrypt decrypt sign
verify all kinds of data through vaults
api now you could do this by using the
Google cloud kms API directly all of the
functionality that we expose in the
plug-in is also available via the API or
the UI directly but we have a lot of
customers who are already heavily
invested in vaults and they wanted to
use the same interface the same policies
the same authentication that they're
already using for their multi cloud
strategy or their hybrid cloud strategy
but they want to leverage Google Cloud
kms and this plugin is a way that you
can do that the coolest part about this
plug-in though is that it actually
allows you to encrypt and decrypt data
backed by a hardware security module in
HSM and this has exposed via the Google
Cloud kms api's so just by reading and
writing from a json rest endpoint you
can actually have your data be encrypted
and decrypted by a physical hardware
security module up to FIPS 140-2 level 3
if you have those regulatory
requirements so again this is GCB native
integrates with called HSM
you can manage your keys using vault you
can use your existing policies and
configurations in vault and you can
encrypt sign verify decrypt data using
the vault API so instead of just showing
you this on a slide I figured I'd show
you what this looks like so with that
we'll jump over to the live demo so I
have a vault server here already set up
it's running on Google kubernetes engine
and I'm just going to go ahead and run
vault read GCP token dev token and what
this is going to do in real time this is
very real
you would theoretically be able to use
that token for the next 60 minutes if I
don't revoke it by the end of this talk
this will give you access to this
project you can't actually do anything
in the project but this is real every
time I run this command I'll actually
get a new Google Cloud access token this
is an access token that I can
authenticate to the API with it is an
OAuth to bearer token and I can give
this to any of the Google Cloud client
libraries or any service account or any
type of officially supported tool and it
will authenticate as this user and be
able to access the api's the permissions
as dictated by I am so that's actually
just how easy it is to generate these
tokens and again they automatically
expire after 60 minutes I've already
configured the GCB kms plugin and I'm
gonna save some typing by copying it to
my clipboard so here I'm using the vault
API to encrypt and decrypt data using
the Google Cloud kms managed keys so all
I do is I ask volt to encrypt some data
in this case I gave it the plaintext hi
and vault gives me back so encrypted
cipher text from here I can also create
new keys rotate keys upgrade keys and
even delete keys all using vault API
under the hood that's backed by Google
Cloud kms and Google Cloud HSM but it's
abstracted for you at the API layer
so all of these secrets engines are
developed by Google as plugins so they
are third-party plugins but they're
bundled automatically in all vault
open-source distributions so even though
they're developed third-party plugins
they're included in vaults distribution
which means you don't have to download
or install them on your own if you
download any recent version of vault
they'll be available for you and as I
said before just like the storage
backends these secrets engines support
the Google cloud application default
credentials which means you don't have
to worry about passing around service
accounts if you're on a Google managed
VM or something with instance metadata
so the last thing I want to talk about
is off methods so we've talked about how
you can run vault on GCP we've talked
about how you can provision accounts and
interact with kms but if i'm a google
cloud user maybe i'm a g suite user
google cloud user I have these service
accounts how do my humans or my
applications authenticate to vault using
GCP in other words can i leverage GCP as
my source of trust for my underlying
authentication and we can we actually
have the Google cloud off method in
vault an off method is the way in which
we convert a human or machine supplied
information into an authentication
credential and this is what it looks
like we can log into vault using the GCP
method with a particular role a service
account and the underlying service
account credentials vault will
authenticate this against the Google
Cloud I am api's and it will give me
back a vault session vault token if you
will and this allows me to then interact
with vault given any pre-configured
policies that my security team might
have created in advance so this is GCP
native it allows you to authenticate
with I am service accounts or GCE
instance metadata so you can actually
authenticate to vault
just because you are an instance in GCE
or anything that has instance metadata
and it has support for vault group
aliases and policy management which is
really important if you're running vault
enterprise and you want to use
namespaces so very quickly let me show
you what this looks like
it's thinking so it does take a little
bit longer because we have to make a few
different API calls to authenticate the
request but what I did here is I gave
vault my credential as well as the
service account that I'm authenticating
with and the role in which I'm
authenticating and vault gives me back a
token that token has some policies so I
basically get a session with policies
attached that were configured and
managed by my security team so I just
authenticate to vault using my existing
Google Cloud credentials so this is a
great way to kind of trust vault as kind
of the source of truth for secrets but
then leverage the identity bits to
Google Cloud on google kubernetes engine
or any kubernetes cluster we also have
the kubernetes off method now this is
not something that Google engineers have
specifically developed we've partnered
with a number of folks including folks
at Hoshi Corp to write the kubernetes
off method but this is a way to
authenticate pods and services in
kubernetes engine using vault
this is GCP agnostic it allows you to
restrict access via our back permissions
and various kubernetes service accounts
you can restrict access by kubernetes
namespaces and it works great on gke
because gk is just kubernetes but this
also works if you have G key on prem
with ombos if you have your own IKS
cluster or eks cluster because this is
kubernetes native it'll work on all of
those as well so these off methods are
developed as plugins that are some of
them are maintaining contributed by
Google and Google engineers they are
also bundled in the open-source
distribution of vault so again you don't
have to worry about installing them
yourselves they just have a separate
development velocity than vault core and
they help solve that first secret
problem how do I authenticate the vault
without like hard coding or credentials
somewhere how does all of this work so
these off methods help you do that do
that by delegating trusts to either the
cloud platform or the kubernetes api
server so I have a few links if you're
going to take a picture of a slide this
is the one to take a picture of there
are a few things here that are really
important the cloud spanner in the
clouds
storage backends are heavily documented
as well as all of our secret engines
including all of our off methods so
everything i've talked about here today
is on this slide except the last one and
i have one minute left
so i'm actually going to show it to you
so the vault fluent d' configurations
allow us to abstract vault
audit logs and system logs into
stackdriver in a really friendly way and
i'm glad i have an extra minute because
this is just really cool to me so i'm
gonna go ahead and jump over here into
the Google Cloud console and make this a
little bit bigger I've configured this
in advance
I've configure this in advance so again
I'm running vault on GCE VMs in this
case you know notice if I click on this
little drop down I have two tags the
vault project IO audit and vault project
IO server the audit logs are actually
vault audit logs vault audits every
request and response in the system and
the server logs are just the operational
logs what you would expect to see from
kind of any microt service or any
long-running service I'm gonna go ahead
and filter by the audit logs here here
are audit logs where and this is
directly using that fluent e
configuration I have my IP address the
alias idea of the credential the API
method I used and the path that I
accessed and right inside stackdriver I
can actually drill down into the direct
request and response headers in the JSON
payload this is structured this is
available and I can actually filter
directly on some of this data so if I
just want to click show matching entries
I can see all of the requests that that
particular token made right from inside
stackdriver and this is not both
specific but this is those fluency
configurations allow the audit logs to
be parsed in a way that stackdriver
exposes this functionality to you that's
all I have for you here today thank you
all so very much I'll be available for
questions outside of the deaf zone thank
you
[Music]